from cnr.com Epstein dos quote he said
that one time that Clinton likes them
young referring to girls Bill Clinton of
course is named in the documents as a
friend of Jeffrey Epstein and uh who
likes them young now I will I just want
to clarify real quick the the date is is
is uh appearing incorrectly probably
because it's like there's some
publishing thing I want make sure that's
clear because people are going to be
like hey why does the date say January
4th on January 3rd but uh so we just put
this up this is the story the documents
have dropped and the site that was
hosting them crashed
almost instantly now I want to make
we're going to be very very careful on
this one the documents have just come
out these are court records and the
names are all unsealed so not every
single name a few names are being
withheld because they're saying that
their lives are in danger but of course
Clinton Clinton was expected to be named
he is named so far I can't say based on
the uh work our journalists and other
journalists are doing that Bill Clinton
is directly implicated in overt
wrongdoing we do know that Clinton was a
friend of Epstein who flew on the plane
and that uh let me let me read the story
for you
Bill Clinton was prominently featured in
the newly unsealed documents from the
Epstein case court documents connected
to Epstein sex trafficking were unsealed
and made public on Wednesday evening in
a document titled exhibit 5 from
Virginia jefra V gilan Maxwell there's a
transcript of the deposition of Johanna
sh uh soberg how do you pronounce that
yoerg has accused prince Andrew of
sexual abuse when she was a minor which
she says was orchestrated by Epstein
Maxwell during the deposition sherg was
questioned by jef's attorney segrid s
mcau about for for President Bill
Clinton do you know if Bill Clinton was
a friend of Jeffrey Epstein mcau asked I
knew he had dealings with Bill Clinton I
did not know they were friends until I
read the Vanity Fair article about them
going to Africa together did Jeffrey
ever talk to you about Bill Clinton
question McCaul quot he said one time
that Clinton likes them young referring
to girls oh boy said I had dealings so
here's this is actual uh uh from the
from the court documents soberg said she
did not meet Clinton or personally see
him him on the island Clinton was
previously identified in the Epstein
case as doe 36 is he is named in dozens
of the redacted court filings so first
name on the list everybody was was was
looking for and expected to see ABC News
a bunch of iset said Clinton would be on
it is on it what can we extrapolate from
Epstein saying he likes him young look
let's let's hold our horses a little bit
first I give Bill Clinton very little
benefit of the doubt nor what I give
Epstein in these documents there are
accusations I mean these are shocking
things Mario on Twitter posting an
excerpt that a a a woman claims Epstein
had Allan dtz rape her and she was a
minor so when Epstein says he likes him
young what do you think Young means to a
guy who's trafficking minors I ain't giv
any of these people the benefit benefit
of the doubt yeah I think the standard
here is that they're all minor when they
say he likes them young a super minor
impubescent is almost what you know like
I don't know what that means but it
means good well this is this the
terrifying and creepy thing if these if
these guys we know are trafficking
minors and they say he likes him Young
in reference to the already underage
girls yeah it sounds like these are
these are young children yeah I but but
but again again these documents don't
prove any of that it's just a statement
from Epstein it could very well be that
when he's like he likes him Young The
Young is a wink wink underage right
and that's what they're doing so he
could just be explaining exactly what
they do but I got to tell you man
somebody walks up up walks up to me on
the street let's just say some random
dude with crazy hair missing teeth black
eyes bloody nose and he's twitching and
he goes Bill Clinton is is is hooking up
with underage girls on EP Island I'd be
like oh yeah I heard that like I you you
could be the craziest looking dude I'm
going to be like uh-huh yeah tell me
more they should all be punished to the
fullest extent of the law and there is
not one thing that is going to happen to
any of them at all maybe maybe
dtz uh but I think that it's unlikely
and it's also extremely unfortunate
Florida has great laws about this
recently passed laws about this and I
would love to see them all punished I
would love to see them all prosecuted in
Florida and if they are found guilty
they should be I think one of the
problems is that they're going to start
trying to spin this to be like Trump is
more involved than he says he is like
there's one document that I'm looking at
right now that's talking about a plain
said at one point I worked at the spa
Mar Lago and that's where I met Glen
Maxwell and then she brought me over to
Epstein and they're going to try and
make it such a a ridiculous claim but
again people only read the headline that
should be considered that should be
obvious to everyone considering the
media that should that should I mean
that goes without saying that they're
going to be doing everything I just
think that we're sadly and I really mean
this in the most tragic way we're so
polarized that people will have such
strong confirmation by us that they will
just hyper fixate regardless of what
happens on Trump and it's a lost cause
all this will disappear and you know
that's what I worry about most but no no
I'm just keep going saying yes no so the
question is how do you how do you combat
that how do you make this a story that
continues on forward and keep attention
on it it that you're never going to
break that hypert tribalism and so the
fact that we now have these docs and
these names and these accusations again
there's still accusations by Witnesses
because this was not a criminal trial
but I think when you get a woman saying
that dtz raped her we should be like hey
maybe we should continue that
investigation into this guy mhm because
we have an accusation from him hey me
too remember yeah go out the window when
it's not convenient anymore that's right
but I'm I want I want to add to this man
it is day three of
2024 y'all knew it was coming it's
coming quick uh I I tweeted it has begun
on New Year's when 2024 strikes and
apparently let freaked people out as I'm
told people were got I I'll keep it a
little bit private but people were like
yeah that really freaks people out and
I'm like I didn't say that it says
2024 the abstein documents it's it's
like we're sitting on a powder keg and
somebody walked up with a with a couple
five gallon drums of gasoline and placed
them on top of that Powder Keg and then
gave us a wink and walked away because
like you like you're mentioning Han clir
with mention of trump in it it's going
to be I I said this is going to happen I
said the other day Trump's name will be
in it and the media is going to say
Donald Trump named in court documents no
one on the left is going to research end
care they're going to run with it and be
like see that proves it yeah yeah we're
headline driven and then the narrative
is going to become about that this
should be a wakeup call to the entire
country when you really think about
what's going on here when you really
think about how corrupt deep and sick
this is like it's so disturbing and yet
somehow we're we're sitting here we're
talking about it like it's not even
something you talk about I'm I'm I'm
actually waiting a little bit before we
get and we because we got these segments
planned I I want to get into this stuff
like the ders stuff yeah it's sick
statement someone super chated uh Soul
kit and said sounds like the October
surprise came early oh no no no see if
this is January wa until yeah if this is
January you wait until October I this is
CRA the the look the documents come out
an hour ago and some of the tweets that
are already going out are like I'm I'm
I'm scared to say not because of polit
political stuff it's because people got
kids at home that are listening MH you
going to have to explain when read
through court documents about what
dershwitz is accused of doing Brunell is
accused of doing and then Brunell turns
up dead youo nobody believes abste
killed himself MH no even if he did like
I we talked about this last night even
if he did kill himself it kind of
doesn't matter because he he like he
killed himself because of what was
happening so because everything not
because of guilt because he doesn't want
to face any well exactly but the point
is what he had done and the consequences
would be so dramatic because he's done
such terrible things he didn't do them
by himself I just like to point out like
we know no that okay first let's start
from the beginning powerful government
leaders order the the murder of people
all the time M yeah it is not a
conspiracy theory to say that Barack
Obama ordered people dead it is not a
Obama ordered the killing of American
citizens without due process without due
process we know this for a fact yes no
but but but we could be careful we could
be careful because there's there's
there's arguments in the Press about
what really happened with the killing of
anoir alaki and Abdul Raman alaki and
there were other American citizens but
no no no Barack Obama ordered these
military actions which resulted in the
death I like to be fair about it right
if we know in the New York Times bang
16-year-old American citizen killed by
by Barack Obama and when the Obama
Administration questioned they said
Whoopsie Daisy we were targeting someone
else when uh uh lukowski's Team we are
change when they questioned it was uh uh
who it Charlie Gibbs I can't remember
who I want to be careful it's been 10
years but when he questions these guys
and says why was an American citizen
killed the guy goes he should have had a
better father and that is what the
president is doing so it's crazy to
think that with Epstein nobody believes
he killed himself this other guy Jean
Luke brell who was found dead in his
prison cell nobody believes he killed
himself everybody was like how long
until gilain is gone it's crazy to think
that everybody knows it's a it's a I
love this saying it's a secret to
everybody right you know that one from
Legend of Zelda meaning it's a secret
everybody knows it's true right it's
like it's it's it's we're supposed to
pretend that this that there's no one
out there just killing the enemies of
powerful Elites it's a conspiracy out in
the open ex yeah but but it's it's it's
crazy to see their whole mechanism for
doing this is broken well I mean they're
just doing it in your face because they
can I mean the conspiracy now is not
that Epstein didn't kill himself it said
Epstein did kill himself that's the
minority position that would be the
weird position to take for sure I mean
think it's challenging because there are
so many characters involved in this that
people who are aware of this will
recognize and know sort of who to dig
through the documents for but for the
average American they know kind of who
Epstein is they know that he died they
know that weirdly he's connected to
something but because the subject is so
repugnant people don't want to talk
about you know especially the rape of
minors they don't want to talk about
sexual assault that they aren't going to
want to talk about it's similar to me to
the beginnings of the Larry Nasser trial
right like it was so abhorent it was so
terrible that this person who was given
authority over young children was able
to uh hurt them so badly but that also
there were lots of people who could have
intervened and did nothing and that was
what I think really awoke a lot of
people to this idea that these big
institutions aren't to be trusted but
now you have people who they recognize
right like they don't think prince
Andrew could do this and if he did they
don't want to think about the details of
it there's going to be a resistance to
going for the truth thanks for watching
this clip from the timcast IRL podcast
hang out with us live Monday through
Friday at 8:00 p.m. and become a member
over at timcast.net